no es sueño ni muy pequeño ni muy grande
siempre que cumplimos un proyecto que
nos proponemos siempre vamos a lograr
convertirnos en una mejor versión de
nosotros mismos
pero eso sí hay que ser realistas hay
que conocer nuestras fortalezas y
nuestras debilidades
si después era un sueño en el que
tengamos que trabajar duro y luchar muy
fuerte
pero que esté dentro de nuestras
limitaciones entonces así pues correr
330 km para mí que he corrido toda la
vida
era algo realizable pero para alguien
que nunca ha hecho deporte en su vida
podría ser correr 5 kilómetros
igualmente de ballet
querer es poder
pero hay que empezar a trabajarlo hoy
el tour de los gigantes 330 kilómetros
en los alpes italianos
nunca este ponemos centroamericano
de las carreras más duras del mundo
tenía que empezar a trabajar hoy mismo y
es que
nunca va a llegar el momento perfecto
uno nunca se va a sentir que ya está
listo para empezar
el mañana nunca llega el mañana medios
muy tarde hay que empezar a trabajarlo
hoy hoy es el momento ahora es el
momento
y entonces yo digo imposible qué es eso
tal vez sea que me ve en la calle yo soy
una mujer de cuarenta y pico de años
chica de unos sesenta de altura mamá que
trabajo de 9 a 5 nadie va a pensar hoy
esa señora de fijo puede correr 330 km
es más para la gente en la calle le digo
mira que yo voy a poner 330 kilómetros
soy mamá trabajo de 9 a 5
no tengo patrocinios probablemente van a
decir así esta señal está totalmente
loca es imposible que logre algo así
y yo pienso imposible que es eso
imposible para mí es quedarme ahí
sentada y ver qué pasa el tiempo que
nunca ni siquiera lo intente
y bueno para empezar a trabajar yo
siempre presento mi proyecto analizo
estudio buscó información para tener un
panorama más claro a lo que voy a
enfrentar
y así descubrí 330 km en los alpes
italianos las montañas más duras y más
altas de europa
27.000 metros de ascenso acumulado
cómo subir y bajar el everest tres veces
siete puestos de asistencia uno cada
cincuenta kilómetros en esos puestos voy
a encontrar agua comida refugio se puede
dormir no más de dos horas porque hay
muy pocas camas y somos 865 corredores
ahí puedo ver a mi esposo me pueda dar
apoyo
y qué debo hacer también tengo que
encontrar no sólo qué debo hacer para
prepararme sino los requisitos que
necesito para estar ahí
y bueno empezar un proyecto de cero
nunca es fácil
yo siempre creo un plan un plan de
acción al que me voy a esperar para
conseguir
y así empecé a investigar y empecé a ver
el equipo reglamentario y había cosas
que nunca mi idea ya utilizaba crampones
para la nieve ropa para menos 12 grados
un salve que mucho más grande para
cargar todo lo que tenía que llevar
realmente leer eso me ponía un poco
nervioso y me asusto pero al mismo
tiempo me emociono mucho porque para
poder llegar y vencer ese proyecto y
datos direct deben ser límites que nunca
habían vencido
mi entrenamiento quedó más o menos así
tengo que entrenar pesas al menos dos
veces a la semana
entrenar funcionales al menos tres veces
a la semana
correr mínimo cinco días a la semana y
de esos cinco días dos días de fondo ir
aumentando el volumen hasta llegar a 160
kilómetros por semana
soy el chico al menos unas dos veces y
si puedo correr dos carreras de
distancias un poco inferiores pero con
un terreno similar sonaba como un plano
muy duro muy fuerte pero al final es mi
sueño y si yo no trabajo duro por él
nadie lo va a hacer por mí
hay que apegarse al plan sin excusas
ser perseverante y disciplinado ser
perseverante y disciplinado ser
perseverante y disciplinado siempre me
repito es en mi cabeza cuando tengo
ganas de darme por vencida cuando siento
que ya no puedo más
y bueno se van a presentar obstáculos
al correr 330 kilómetros en la montaña
hay mil cosas que pueden suceder
cansancio una lesión un accidente
pero estos obstáculos son escalones que
me van a hacer crecer como persona y
estar más lista más preparada para todo
lo que venga en la vida
en ese momento cuando empecé a
prepararme para esta carrera unos meses
después mi suegra se enfermó y murió
unas veces después como era de esperar
en una pareja de 60 años juntos mi
suegro también enfermo
él era el pilar de la familia de mi
esposo y debo decir que como bombero que
era era el que más me apoyaba en todas
estas locuras de montaña fue un golpe
muy duro
todo cambió
generalmente en mi esposo me acompañaba
a entrenar o me daba soporte pero eso ya
no era posible por esta situación y tuve
que empezar a entrenar en solitario
me acuerdo una vez que iba camino al
chirripó hacer un entrenamiento de subir
y bajar y cuando iba de camino mi esposo
me llamó y me dijo papá se puso mal pero
si yo le aviso cualquier cosa
creo que ese día fue el día que tengo el
récord de subir y bajar el sirvo más
rápido todo el tiempo iba pensando
preocupada por favor de un hijo que no
se muera
yo tengo la necesidad de despedirme
y bueno
esos son obstáculos que enfrentamos cada
vez que nos ponemos un proyecto
hay que tomarlos en cuenta yo pienso que
son parte de y si los vemos así como
parte de es más fácil encontrar las
soluciones las soluciones deben ser
rápidas inmediatas no hay que dejarlos a
un lado hay que solucionarlos
inmediatamente hay que aprender a
resolver
si se presentan obstáculos lo resolvemos
inmediatamente por eso yo cuando tras un
plan de trabajo siempre dedicó una parte
a esos imprevistos a esos problemas que
voy a enfrentar porque así me preparo y
estoy lista para saber que cuando se
presentan no resuelve inmediatamente y
sigo con el proceso
no es nada fácil
pero es que nada que vale la pena en la
vida viene fácil y sin esfuerzo
apoyo y trabajo en equipo
pienso que cuando uno tiene un proyecto
involucra a su familia ya sus amigos y
otras personas es mucho más fácil
un proyecto compartido siempre alivian
el peso
en ese momento mi mayor apoyo soy
honesta siempre ha sido mi esposo
y ahí lo veía justo ahí pasando unos
momentos más duros de su vida su mamá
acaba de morir y su papá lo iba a hacer
en cualquier momento
eran momentos muy duros
pero yo sabía que si logramos
sobrellevar eso luego me di cuenta que
fue lo que me dio la fuerza mental para
poder lograr vencer lo que venía en este
gran reto que me estaba proponiendo
mis entrenadores mis entrenadores
también jugaron un gran papel ellos me
dan sus consejos está bien por lo que
estaba pasando sabía en la gran hazaña
que me estaba proponiendo y se dedicaron
100% a mí todos los aportes todos se
entregan fue algo
que me ayudó muchísimo
me acuerdo que una de las últimas
conversaciones que tuve con mi suegro
los voy a visitar
y me dijo mi hijita como está
cómo se siente cómo se prepara para ese
reto
yo estoy segura que usted lo puede
lograr por favor no se preocupe por mí
y bueno
desde ahí
pienso que fue la motivación que
necesitaba
y es que claro un proyecto necesita
mucho trabajo mucha perseverancia mucha
disciplina pero una herramienta muy
fuerte para conseguir eso es la
motivación
entonces de ese momento mi motivación
mayor fue dedicarle en la carrera
dedicarle ese evento toda la preparación
a ti tu que estaba ahí en su lecho de
muerte seguro de que yo lo podía lograr
también la visualización desde ahí cada
entrenamiento que realice me
transportaba a los alpes cada vez que
corría me sentía como si estuviera
corriendo por los parajes que iba a
vivir me imaginaba cruzando la meta esa
energía era sumamente poderosa
presidencia
el empuje final
de acuerdo que mi viaje
nuestro viaje estaba planeado para un
martes a las 3 de la tarde el domingo
previo
mi esposo y yo conversamos y decidimos
cancelarlo al día siguiente
es el lunes en la madrugada
mi suegro murió no todos los tiempos de
cancelarlo
el lunes fue la vela el martes del
entierro
no habíamos cancelado el vuelo y cuando
nos dimos cuenta
decidimos dedicarle todo a él
y hacer el viaje un americano recogió de
cementerios y nos llevó al aeropuerto
todavía no entiendo ni como el para qué
ya en la carrera fue una carrera
durísima el clima era super frío a los
segundos días tenía una bronquitis y los
doctores querían sacarme de la carrera
pero yo todo ese trabajo yo no me vas al
vencer además se lo había prometido mi
suegro
avance y avance esos 233 kilómetros día
y noche corriendo subiendo y bajando
montañas imponentes
vi cabras salvajes siempre les había
querido ver hablé con ellas conocí
muchísimos corredores de todo el mundo
en todo el tiempo a veces me sentía en
lo más alto del mundo y a veces lo más
insignificante
trabajar por esa meta este es el premio
muchas veces trabajamos trabajamos por
este proyecto y si vemos para atrás nos
damos cuenta que aunque no lo logremos
ya somos personas diferentes todo ese
esfuerzo toda esa dedicación toda esa
disciplina ya nos ha convertido en
personas más completas
vemos para atrás y somos una persona muy
diferente a la que comenzó el proyecto
todo este trabajo es todo ese esfuerzo
ya valió la pena
cruzar la meta del toro
todo el trabajo el esfuerzo la
perseverancia el sacrificio tuvo su
fruto lo logré
primera mujer centroamericana en cruzar
la meta del tour de jams 330 kilómetros
y los datos fueron así 120 horas 49
minutos y 32 segundos corriendo sin
parar de eso sólo logré dormir ocho
horas posición 102 en general de 865
corredores
posición general femenina 12 de 256
mujeres
ese año sólo el 63% logró terminar el
evento
que puedo concluir yo de todo esto
yo sé a mí me encanta correr estos
eventos extremos los disfruto
y claro las fotos las noticias las
revistas los reportajes todo suena como
algo épico y de ensueño pero la gente
tiene que entender que no es sólo eso
que hay mucho más detrás de todo eso hay
mucho mucho trabajo mucho esfuerzo
problemas resolver planear sacrificios
y claro si al final logramos salir de
todo eso utilizar las herramientas que
aprendimos pues si se convierte en algo
épico y del sueño
a veces cuando termine un evento y veo
mi número todo el lugar borroso
destruido
pienso que si estuve yo en algún momento
del reto y que todas esas herramientas
que adquirí durante el proceso fueron
las que me ayudaron a salir con éxito de
estas situaciones
tal vez para ustedes no sea correr 330
km en la montaña tal vez sea un proyecto
tal vez sea estudiar una carrera
pero yo les digo
no lo piensen más no están locos si se
puede
empiecen a luchar por ese sueño hoy
mañana ya es muy tarde mañana nunca
llega